[Applause]
[Music]
New Zealand the remote Pacific aripo
home of the All Blacks and their famous
prematur editions of the hucka land of
Polynesian Warriors and of the most
visible political figure that this
country has had in recent decades we're
talking of course of progressive leader
jinda ardern that young political figure
whom many came to regard as the new face
of all global social democracy urn
becomes New Zealand's most popular PM in
a century Paul however what goes up
eventually must come down and that's
just what happened to good old ardern
the covid-19 crisis triggered other
crises in the Kiwi Nation inflation High
Cost of Living skyrocketing housing
prices the perfect formula for losing
the confidence of citizens unless of
course you're in Argentina as it turns
out at the last election of 14th of
October 2023 this is what happened to
ard's former party New Zealand elects
its most conservative government in
decades the right word shift came as
voters punished to the party once led by
jinda ardern for failing to deliver the
transformational change that it had
promised new zealanders voted for a new
government to end the six years of ard's
Labor government the country is not
going through the best of times and
Kiwis want Solutions but what if I told
you that New Zealand faces more than
just internal threats what if I told
told you that China is an increasingly
concerning player for the Kiwi Nation
visual politic viewers what can I say
China's tentacles continue to spread
around the world and New Zealand and its
neighborhood are no exception be that as
it may all of this has made us on visual
politic ask ourselves a few questions
what Legacy does jinda UR leave in New
Zealand what does the shift to the right
mean for this country what role will
China play in all of this mess and one
last question did you know that New
Zealand is our favorite country all
right let's get
[Music]
started loved around the globe rejected
at
home so far this Century there have been
world leaders who have stood out above
others both for better and For Worse
Barack Obama Donald Trump Angela Merkel
Putin well we could say that this has
also been the case with jinda Ard Ard
who came to power in 2017 leading a
coalition government with the greens and
New Zealand first a populist and
nationalist party soon emerged as the
major flag bearer of what is known as
the international new social democracy
in fact her profile reached the heights
of popularity in 2020 after having to
deal with two crises that catapulted her
to
stardom on the 15th of March 2019 the
New Zealand city of Christ Church
suffered a terrorist attack that killed
51 Muslims in two mosques the attack
which had significant International
repercussions led ardern to quickly and
aggressively regulate gun ownership in
New Zealand in less than a week she
managed to get Parliament to pass a new
law regulating ownership in a more
restrictive manner this Swift action
along with the empathy and closeness she
showed to the families of the victims
greatly strengthened her reputation both
locally and internationally however it
was her response to the covid-19 crisis
that secured her a place on the podium
of the world's most influential figures
the nation's Swift reaction to the
pandemic establishing strict
restrictions as early as February 2020
when there were only a few cases
reported nationally conducting Mass
testing campaigns and getting the
population to correctly comply with the
restrictions led to New Zealand becoming
one of the countries where covid-19 had
the least presence and the least
mortality without going any further here
on visual politic we gave our d one of
our Awards precisely for this quick
response and of course due to this very
reason we should not be surprised that
in the October 2020 elections she would
have a landslide Victory New Zealand
prime minister jinda ardern's Landslide
victory in her second term urn won an
absolute majority that allowed her to
govern alone so after the initial shock
of the pandemic the Prime Minister
promised to focus on economic recovery
however the plans would not turn out as
the popular kiwi prime minister had in
mind to begin with at the beginning of
2022 the New Zealand population began to
protest in the streets to put an end
once and for all to the covid-19
restrictions which had been in place for
more than 2 years of course that was not
all there were also other reasons for
the rapid decline in ardern's popularity
High inflation an ever increasing cost
of living stratospheric housing prices
to give you an idea between 2017 and
2021 housing prices Rose 58% with the
average price of a home reaching $1
million New Zealand dollar that's about
$600,000 at the the current exchange
rate meanwhile ardern's promise to build
100,000 new homes came to nothing the
ardern government far from being
self-critical tried to put all the blame
for the general deterioration of the
country on the murky International
scenario the world is experiencing the
worst economic shock since the Great
Depression with the war in Ukraine and
covid-19 related supply chain issues
adding to it with the worst inflation
spike in decades finally in the face of
popular pressure at the beginning of
2023 we saw for this news jenda urn is
stepping down as prime minister of New
Zealand the leader internationally
acclaimed for her more than 5 years in
office will step down in February urn
eventually resigned from her position
her profile had deteriorated very
rapidly during her second term in office
and along with her that of the labor
party ardern's successor Chris Hipkins
was unable to reverse the negative Trend
in the polls and in mid October of this
year what many had already predicted
ended up happening there was a new con
conservative Victory but who will be the
next prime minister and even more
importantly what are his or her plans
for New Zealand well pay very very close
attention the conservative
[Music]
Revival on the 14th of October this year
new zealanders were called to the polls
to decide the future path of their
country however given how threadbear the
labor party was everyone knew what the
final outcome of the election would be
and indeed there were no surprises the
National Party representing the
conservative wing of kiwe politics
outperformed labor by a wide margin for
many analysts this election has been the
final blow to jinda ardern's Legacy but
who is it that has managed to beat labor
well this man you see here Christopher
luxon luxen who has been a major
businessman in among other companies Air
New Zealand did not begin his political
career until 2020 when he started out as
a junior MP however one year after
joining the National Party he became the
party's leader yes these things do
happen in New Zealand luxen has often
been identified as a Christian in a
particularly secular country we're
talking about a politician who
acknowledges being both socially and
fiscally conservative that is he opposes
Reliance on subsidies and believes in
low taxes and reduced public spending
nevertheless contrary to what many might
think luxen also Embraces other ideas
that have tradition Al been identified
with a more shall we say progressive
line such as the fight against climate
change or support for the LGBT community
even so such issues have taken a
backseat in this campaign where luxon
has focused first and foremost on two
key objectives improving the economy and
reducing the lack of
[Music]
security you see New Zealand officially
went into recession in the middle of
2023 so luxon's proposals have focused
on getting the economy back on track by
improving one of the country's weakest
aspects its low productivity since the
1970s New Zealand's labor productivity
has been stagnating and is now below the
obcd average which has hit wages hard
this stagnation is due to the limits of
its two main economic sectors
Agriculture and livestock it's really
hard to get an extra liter of milk out
of a cow it's really hard to get big
productivity gains out of Tourism we
don't have lots of our economy in areas
where there are productivity gains even
from small Investments like it Advanced
manufacturing Pharmaceuticals those are
areas where you can see huge uplifts in
productivity so that's a challenge
what's more the fact that New Zealand is
among 10 of the most restrictive obcd
countries for foreign investment inflows
does not help to solve this problem
therefore in order to improve
productivity and boost economic recovery
luxon has pledged among other things to
balance the Public Accounts reduce the
tax burden make the entry of foreign
Capital more flexible and attract Talent
from abroad a very capitalist program
however luxon was also aware that
citizens were concerned about an almost
new problem in the country an increasing
lack of
security you see in New Zealand and
Australia what we have been seeing in
various cities throughout the United
States is happening burglaries of
commercial establishments are
continually soaring in fact so far this
has cost Australia and New Zealand
together about .4 billion us we are
talking about a 45% increase in
commercial burglaries in New Zealand in
2022 a country that is usually very
quiet and safe as a result during the
campaign luxen puts special emphasis on
the fight against Crime Check It Out
National would bring back military boot
camps for young offenders National
announc his plan for 300 more Frontline
police to tackle Inner City crime luxon
understood what the kiwis were looking
for he promised to improve the country's
economy and security and thus won the
election however many are now also
wondering what its foreign policy will
be like and above all what exactly its
Position will be in regards to an
increasingly present China in the South
Pacific will there be any change from
the labor position of recent years well
let's find
[Music]
out with China tough or
soft on this channel we have already
talked a few times about the South
Pacific region what we know mainly as
the continent of oceanana and the many
island nations that compose it NAU
kibati Micronesia Vanuatu and a few more
well the fact is that this huge area has
traditionally been one where Australia
above all and also New Zealand to a
lesser extent have had their main sphere
of action in other words it has been and
continues to be their backyard even so
in the last two decades another player
has come into play that has already
achieved immense influence we are
talking of course about
China the Asian giant has not only
become the largest trading partner of
the countries in this part of the South
Pacific but has also managed to position
itself as the third largest donor in the
region behind only Australia and New
Zealand in fact between 2011 and 2017
Chinese Aid to these countries accounted
for 8% of all the official development
assistance they received this rapid
Chinese rise has come about as a result
of the small highly underdeveloped
islands with a distinct lack of
infrastructure reaching out to China and
its offers of loans in order to get
numerous projects off the ground in the
face of this Chinese reproach M with the
region both Australian and New Zealand
analysts have warned of the risks posed
by this development firstly they fear
that China could establish military
bases in these countries something that
is a real possibility given the
agreement it signed with the Solomon
Islands China signed security agreement
with Solomon Islands alarming neighbors
however Australia and even the United
States have already begun to react in
recent months they have been negotiating
intensively with all these micro Nations
to improve standards and funding as well
as to refurbish bases such as the one on
Manus Island in Papa New Guinea so that
China does not take the lead even so
what is certain is that China has been
increasingly strengthening its position
in the South Pacific and faced with this
the Ard ear labor Government tried to do
something i'llbe it rather
[Applause]
inconsistently you see during her first
term a relatively hostile tone prevailed
in the face of the Chinese Advance her
government published a strategy called
Pacific reset it recognized the risk of
Chinese encroachment in the South
Pacific and strengthened New Zealand's
investment in the small islands of the
region around $400 million us to open up
to 10 new diplomatic posts in these
countries and Carry Out many other
projects however when she won her second
election and was able to form a
government alone this attitude changed
completely ardn suddenly embraced a more
conciliatory tone with China prompted by
her foreign affairs minister of Maui
descent Naya mahuta yes ardn continued
to criticize some of the Asian Giants
moves such as the security agreement it
signed with the Solomon Islands but in
general she focused more on reaffirming
the importance of China for kiwi trade
after all more than 30% of all exports
go to the Asian giant
the trade relationship we share with
China for example continues to grow
underpinned by our bilateral Free Trade
Agreement but even as China becomes more
assertive in the pursuit of its
interests there are still shared
interests on which we can and should
cooperate the post-war order and the
rules that underpin it have supported
China's rise and as permanent member of
the security Council China has a crucial
role to play in upholding that order but
with ardern's departure her successor
Chris Hipkins somewhat resumed the
Hardline that characterized ardern's
first term indeed in several security
documents published under his brief
tenure as acting prime minister China
was singled out as the greatest threat
to peace in the region New Zealand warns
of assertive China in First National
Security strategy however this new much
more hostile position adopted by the
labor government under Hipkins may
change again with the arrival of the
conservative luxen in
[Music]
power many expect that he will adopt a
strategy towards China based essentially
on business after all that is his
specialty in fact he has already made it
clear that he would be delighted to join
China's new Silk Road scheme and receive
the $1 15 billion US investment China
has offered the Kiwi Nation yet luxen
will not be able to govern alone and
will have to take into account what are
his two government Partners the ACT a
classic Liberal Party highly critical of
China and New Zealand first the populist
party LED by Winston Peters who was
ard's foreign minister during her first
term and who was precisely the one who
promoted New Zealand's more hostile
position towards China so you see visual
politic Community the New Zealand labor
government is over after 6 years
championing austerity the free market
and an iron fist Christopher luxen has
won the elections and provided there are
no surprises he will be the next prime
minister of New Zealand in other words
he will be in charge not only of dealing
with the economic and security crisis
country is going through but also of
dealing with an increasingly strong
China in the country's backyard if his
government Partners allow him to do so
everything indicates good relations with
the Asian giant after all China is the
country's largest trading partner and if
economic recovery is what he seeks it is
not in his interest to lose it business
and money seem to come first but at this
point the questions now are over to you
do you think luxen will be able to pull
New Zealand out of the crisis will he
become as popular as AR internationally
will he be able to further strengthen
ties with China you can leave me your
answers in the comments and as always
don't forget to he on visual politic we
release new videos every week so
subscribe to this channel hit that
little bell so you don't miss any of our
updates and if you like the video please
like it I'll see you in the next one all
the best see you next
[Music]
time